welcome to the fourth morning of the
satisfiability boot camp it's a pleasure
to introduce
uh jacob nordstrom who's talking about
pseudo-boolean solving and
optimization uh jacob got his
phd from the kth royal
institute um a number of years ago he uh
spent he spent a couple years at mit he
was on the faculty at
copenhagen for quite a few years and
maybe seven or eight years at least and
then
is now a professor again at kth uh he
works
extensively in cutting planes and pseudo
boolean solving and res
and resolution and uh and
and uh resource trade-offs and various
uh i guess related topics um he's uh
i would say one of the one of the few
people who really
has feet firmly planted in both the pure
and applied camps
of satisfiability solving so that's a
very nice place to be and um
so uh i guess without further ado uh
yaakov the floor is yours thank you sam
right um i'm yoga norsham currently
splitting my time between
the university of copenhagen and lund
university
commuting across the bridge except now
in kobe times
i don't do that but today i'm
lecturing from lund university because
we were allowed to do that when we were
teaching or lecturing
and so this is a tutorial on
pseudo-boolean solving and
optimization and
it's divided into four parts which
are pre-recorded but were uploaded shall
we say fairly late
and so perhaps rather than being
preparatory viewing
you can for this talk you can view this
pre-recorded
um lecture has provided more in-depth
information and this
live talk is more like an invitation for
you to go and watch these videos so i'll
i'll start quickly by setting up some
preliminaries
and then i'll talk about the solving of
pseudo-boolean decision
problems then i'll talk about
optimization problems and finally
i hope to touch a bit on also on mixed
integer linear programming
um so let's get started uh so what does
this pseudo boolean thingy mean other
than that it's
obviously a cool name as i've discussed
with albert like who wouldn't
wouldn't want to do sudo boolean solving
so it turns out it's apparently a fairly
well established terminology since the
1960s
what it is you know a pseudo boolean
function is what we theoreticians would
call
a function over the boolean hypercube
that's what it is no more no less so the
inputs are bits
true or false which we think of true
being one
zero being false for the rest of this
talk and then the output
is a real value um
so throughout this talk we'll we'll
think about a slightly restricted
setting where we insist that all
pseudo-boolean functions that we see
will actually be linear forms
this isn't a huge restriction in the
sense that if you have a non-linear
problem you can always linearize but but
i won't talk about that so
so everything you see today will be
linear and even
for linear functions it turns out that
this is very expressible formalism like
most of the
say np complete problems we we know and
love are are very natural to
uh represent the pseudo-boolean problems
so
so but the the name of this program is
satisfiability so why should we care
about
going beyond sat well because
pseudo boolean the pseudo boolean format
is so much nicer than conjunctive normal
form
for instance say that you want to say
that a sum of six variables
is at least three then you can just
write it down in pseudo-boolean form as
the linear inequality if you want to
write it as a set of clauses then it
blows up terribly and you even have to
check it's not even clear what these
clauses mean and you have to check that
this is direct
the correct representation and i hope by
in fact in some previous version of this
talk i even had a typo in this
representation without noticing but i
hope it's correct now
so there's a terrible blow up compared
to
pseudo-boolean form for cnf and also as
we'll talk about a little bit
once you have uh your functions in
pseudo-boolean form you can actually do
more sophisticated and stronger
reasoning on them
than you can do with conflict-driven
clause learning however what's nice is
that you're still
fairly close to sat so you could try to
piggyback on all these amazing
improvements that have
been happening over in the sat community
also you can
try to borrow ideas from zero one
interlinear programming
which uh the the mixed integer linear
programming community is another
community that has been
making tons of progress over the last
decades
and somehow sudo boolean solving sits
right there in the middle
so when i say a pseudo boolean
constraint then i mean some linear form
compared to an integer a
where the comparator is well greater
than or
equal or less than or equal or equality
li throughout this talk will be a
literal that is a
a variable or a negated variable where
negation is bar
and the semantics is that they cancel to
produce a one
zero is false and one is true and in
fact uh
i'll also immediately drop this
generality and insist on so-called
normalized form
we will only acknowledge greater than or
equal
inequalities we will insist on all ais
in a's
being non-negative integers
um and it's not so hard to see that this
is actually without loss of generality
because by this rule you can always
if you have a negative coefficient you
can substitute with the
literal of the opposing sign and rewrite
and in this normalized form
uh we'll refer to a as the degree of
falsity of the constraint
okay so so what are some constraints
that we know of
well if you have a clause that's clearly
a pseudo-boolean constraint because you
just take the sum of the literals and
and claim that at least one of them is
true we saw cardinality constraints that
are
are more general and then you could have
a even more general
fully general pseudo boolean constraints
something like i don't know x1 plus two
x two bar
plus three x three plus four x four bar
plus
five x five greater equals seven
something like that so we'll operate
on these kind of constraints
and a pseudo boolean formula is a
conjunction or a collection of such
constraints
and then there are two problems we can
consider one is the
the solving problem where we are given a
formula we want to know whether it's
satisfiable or feasible
the other problem is when we also have
an objective function that i will try to
write as
summing over i w i l i which we want to
minimize so we always want to minimize
our objective
this is without loss of generality if
you care more about maximization
problems than just
negate your objective function
so that's the preliminaries that we need
and now we'll talk about
uh we'll we'll talk about how to do sudo
boolean solving and optimization
a very related area is so-called max at
solving so we'll talk a bit about that
and i hope to be able to talk also about
integer linear programming or more
generally usually these solvers are
called mixed integer linear programming
solvers
or or mip solvers and
if you have any questions please raise
your hand please write something in the
chat or use the q a i'll try to keep
track of that
um if anything is unclear i should say
that at some points in this talk i
will uh go a bit fast uh
intentionally and when this is the case
i
sort of have added a warning to the
slides and this is because you will find
more
in-depth explanations in the
pre-recorded
uh lectures so pseudo boolean how would
you do it you're given a pseudo-boolean
formula you want to determine
feasibility one approach is
to just keep your input in
pseudo-boolean form
and then whenever it implies something
you do as you propagate as a
conflict-driven close-learning software
would have done and then you just run
standard cdcl conflict analysis so this
will
be in principle uh indistinguishable
from running cdcl except that you happen
to have your input in another form
so i won't say more about it than that
because there's no too much to say about
it
another more sophisticated approach
is to re-encode your problem eagerly
to clauses and then run conflict-driven
driven closely
this is i think one of the early solvers
doing this with with the amazing success
was minister plus
um two good soldiers these days are open
wbo and maps
and then another approach which is dear
to my heart so so
um so we somehow want to harness
conflict-driven
solving ideas and the eager approach
says let's go back to cnf
and use the algorithm over there and
native reasoning with suitable and
constraints
goes in the opposite direction is take
it says no no no let's keep our
pseudo-boolean format
let's try to lift conflict-driven
learning to this setting
and i will most of the talk will focus
on this and the two
most well-developed modern solvers using
this approach that i know
is cypherj developed by the team in
lance france
and rounding sat which is from my
research group
okay so but let's talk briefly about
re-encoding to cnf so
as we saw on the second slide or
something
representing a pseudo boolean format in
c enough is is not necessarily a good
idea we can incur an explanation
blow up so um to to
avoid this we use new extension
variables to get a more
compact encoding and sort of without
going into too much details the idea is
that you
given a pseudo boolean constraint write
down some boolean circuit
evaluating whether this expression is
true or not given your inputs
okay so and now once you have this
circuit there's a standard way
the so-called satan transformation to
write down a cnf formula
that enforces a correct evaluation of
the circuit and at a high level this is
kind of what you do
and then what circuit are you going to
choose well in the
pre-recorded material i have some
examples sequential counters
the totalizer encoding the other network
encoding
i won't go into details about this for
for time reasons
i just want to say that what you there
are two things that you would want from
an encoding at least one is that
if i have a cnf formula f sub c that
encodes the pseudo boolean constraint
then and if i have some partial
assignment under which
the sudo boolean constraints propagates
some consequences propagate some
variable assignments
then i would like my cnf formula to
propagate the same things
so that from the solver point of view
like intuitively speaking
from the solar point of view it doesn't
really matter whether it's operating on
the pseudo-boolean constraint or the cnf
encoding
the propagations are the same and this
is what the solver cares about
in particular if if a partial assignment
already falsifies the constraint then we
would like to see
that the cnf encoding propagates the
contradiction
and this is often referred to as
generalized arc
consistency borrowing terminology from
the constraint
programming community another thing that
would be nice is that your encoding
isn't
too large you want it to be polynomial
size or
and you really care about the polynomial
also so as small as possible this is a
one difference
when you're going from the theory side
to the applied side
in general like polynomial size or
polynomial time algorithms won't be good
enough you're really shooting for like
linear
or maybe quadratic or something every
other linear factor is a
huge problem
it is possible to find encodings that
achieve
both generalized arc consistency and
polynomial
encoding size but apparently they're not
used in practice so
the most popular perhaps encoding or one
of the most popular encodings is the
so-called generalized totalizer encoding
which worst case is exponential time but
seem to be better
than the theoretically polynomial size
encoding in practice
again i won't talk more about this
there's some more in the pre-recorded
tutorial there's much more
in the sat handbook where the second
edition is is just
being printed as we speak so that's like
briefly what i wanted to say about
converting the pseudo boolean formula to
cnf and
and and running a cdcl solver and what
are some
interesting well so how good is this
well it turns out it's really good
sometimes uh in fact the cdcl
based solvers are uh sometimes beating
the crap out of
the native pseudo-boolean solvers that i
will talk about next
so what is the explanation for this so i
don't
know if anyone has really given a
rigorous explanation i think this is a
good theory question
but sort of intuitively one reason why
this would be good
is because of the extension variables
because you're adding extension
variables that are encoding
fairly complex statements like somewhere
halfway through the circuit
you have evaluated parts of your
pseudo-boolean
constraint and you have partial
information and suddenly you have an
extension variable encoding that you
know exactly this
this is something that a native sudo
boolean server does not have access to
but the base solver would have access to
it it wouldn't be able to branch on it
will be able to learn clauses over these
uh variables which if you think about it
will then not just be linear
inequalities as for the
pseudo boolean solver but they can since
these since every variable can like mean
a linear inequality a disjunction of
of such linear inequalities can become
some very general polytope or something
um so it would be super nice to to
this is i'm really just saying fluffy
intuition at this point
somehow making this rigorous would be a
very nice theoretical problem
however this
gain in performance really depends on
getting a nice encoding for instance one
experiment you can do is you can take
your pseudo-boolean formula and you can
permute
the variables or flip the signs of the
literals
and then try to run a cdcl based solver
and then that is can be terrible truly
terrible for performance so somehow
this conversion to cnf you're depending
on someone being nice to you
when you when you get the problem also
there are other examples where
even if you have extension variables the
extension variables are not able to make
connections between
constraints they're just encoding a
single constraint so for instance if you
take a pigeonhole principle formula
in pseudo-boolean form and you
encode it to cnf and you run a cdcl
based solver it will suffer from the
same exponential lower bound that
standard resolution based solvers
would suffer from there's no way you can
beat the pseudo boolean solder
regardless of
what your pseudobudding encoding to cnf
will be
um so uh
but it's it's it's a it's a
it's an entire research area to think
about what are these good
cnf encodings and what are the for
instance trade-offs between propagation
strength and encoding site
size this would be uh i think there's
there would be room for some doing some
computational complexity theory here
uh also to understand when the
cdcl-based approaches are good or bad
compared to the native
pseudo-boolean solvers based on the
cutting planes proof system that i'll
talk about next
to do some more theory on this would be
very nice on the applied side
why not try to build a solver that
harnesses the strength
of the cdcl based approach and the
sodium
pseudo boolean approach there's also a
nice kind of
certification question here or proof
logging question
namely the following that
when you're running a cdcl based server
you have this initial phase where you do
a massive re-encoding
how do you even know after that that
your cnf is is encoded correctly how do
you know that you're solving the correct
problem
for now i think there's there is uh
what you have to do if you're using a
cdcl based suitable solver basically you
have to trust that they know what
they're doing that you're solving the
right cnf
and this is not entirely satisfactory it
would be nice to actually know that you
have translated from pseudo-boolean form
to conjunct the normal form correctly
okay so moving on next to what i refer
to as native
pseudo-boolean solvers here what we want
to do
is uh just we want to do conflict-driven
search and learning as in satsovi and as
has been covered in in previous
tutorials during this bootcamp
but on we want to operate on pseudo
boolean constraints instead of clauses
so what does a cdcl solver do well it
does variable assignments it decides
some variables and then propagates
obvious consequences until it reaches a
conflict
and then you somehow do a derivation to
derive a new constraint
and you backtrack so we want to do all
of this but with pseudobullet
constraints
so how do we do this well so
let us write row to denote the current
assignment that the solver has which is
referred to as the trail
so this is an ordered set of literals
that is assigned to true
and for every literal we know whether
it's a decision that the solver made
freely
or whether it was propagated by some
constraint and if it was propagated then
we know why there's always a reason
constraint explaining the propagation
but what does it mean to propagate well
an important notion here is slack
which measures how far some suitable and
constraints sum by
a i l i greater equal a how far is it
from being falsity
by row how much margin is there how much
slack is there
well the slack that you have is you can
take
all the literals that are either
satisfied
or unassigned by row so they're either
already contributing or they could
potentially contribute
but the falsified literatures were
ignoring because they're not
contributing
and let's sum up all those coefficients
this is like the best case contribution
note here i'm importantly using this
normalized form now so that we know that
all of these coefficients and the degree
of falsity they're positive numbers
so the best possible contribution we can
get from the left-hand side is
summing over all non-false divided
literals ai
and then we know that we need to achieve
at least a so we subtract a
this is the margin okay let's illustrate
this on the
constraint that we saw at the beginning
so the empty assignment here you can see
that you could satisfy everything
that would give us 15 on the left minus
seven
on the right that's eight so the slack
here is eight
however if the solar falsifies x5 then
we lose this contribution and the slack
goes down to
three and now interestingly this slack
is
smaller than the coefficient of not x4
and what this means is if you think
about it that we cannot afford
setting x4 to the wrong value because if
so there's no way we can reach 7.
if we screw up x4 also then the best we
can get here is 6 but we need 7.
so this is the notion of pseudo-boolean
propagation when a coefficient is
strictly larger than the slack it should
propagate
good so let's suppose the solver
propagates this doesn't change the slack
because we contributed in the right
direction
then the solver goes off for a while and
it sets x3 to
to false and x2 to true say for other
reasons
and now you see that the slack is -2
so we have a contribution from from x4
and we have a potential contribution
from x1 so that's five
but we want seven so slack is minus two
and we have a conflict and note
interestingly that
in contrast to cdcl uh we haven't even
assigned
all the variables in this constraint but
we already know that we screwed it up
there's no way we can save the situation
now
so this is a conflict although we
haven't assigned all the variables
okay good so now we know how to do
variable decisions and propagations now
we need to think about conflict analysis
so consider this the following cdcl
trail suppose we have this
cnf formula over here and suppose the
solver decided w
to false and then propagated u and it
decided x to false and then it
propagated until it so happened that it
falsified
this clause over here so what would cdcl
conflict analysis do
well it would first so first note that
the this trail here this partial truth
value assignment obviously falsifies the
conflict clause that's
why it's a conflict and now what we do
in the first step
is that we take this conflict clause and
the reason and we resolve it
over z and remove z and get a new clause
x or not y
which is falsified even when we remove z
from the trail when we remove z from the
partial assignment
so even before assigning z this clause
already explains that we
have gone wrong here continuing the
conflict analysis
we resolve this clause with this recent
clause over y
to get u or x and now if we remove you
from the trail
u or x explains that already this
partial assignment above here is wrong
and this is an important invariant in in
conflict-driven clause learning
conflict analysis like every derived
constraint that we have
explains why the partial assignment done
so far
is wrong why it can't fly
and then by maintaining this invariant
we just run
our conflict analysis until we get a
clause that we like
and when we get a clause that we like we
say ah here we can terminate i'm going
to
learn this clause and add it to my
formula and i won't go into
uh what like means but this is the
concept of the
the constraint being asserting that when
i backtrack it will flip some variable
so this is you can see uh
more details on this in my in my
pre-recorded talk
or um in the tutorial that we had on
on conflict live and closed learning
solving earlier in the week
okay good so now we know what cdcl does
it like it takes
constraints and uses the resolution rule
so we want to do the same thing
okay so suppose here is a resolution
step and
it's a easy observation that we can
actually mimic
this in sudo boolean reasoning suppose
we have so this
clause would be translated into this
pseudo-boolean constraint and this
clause is this constraint
and we can add them up and then
z will cancel and we'll get x plus 2y
bar greater equal one which semantically
is
the same thing as this clause okay
so and i'll refer to this as the
generalized resolution rule
where you take two constraints you have
a variable occurring with opposite signs
potentially you need to multiply the two
constraints to get the same coefficient
here we don't need to do that we have
all coefficients one and then you add
and the variable cancels so this is
resolution over x1
okay except that if you
paid attention you see that this 2
shouldn't be here i mean in a resolution
step we should actually have derived x
plus y bar greater equal not 2y-bar
but this we can also conclude because if
you think about it the only way this
constraint can be true
over the integers is that this
constraint is also true
because there's no way you need a
contribution from some coefficient here
that is larger than degree of falsity so
without loss of generality
you can always bring down all
coefficients to at most the degree of
falsity
and this is known as the saturation rule
importantly this is not
sound over the reels
it's only sound over the integers but
that's
good news for us because we want some
roots that are not sound over
the reels if we want to do boolean set
solving otherwise we would just be
doing linear programming and then we
couldn't solve boolean problems
um and in fact i should say for fairness
sake that
the way hooker defined generalized
resolution is that he included
this this fix but it's convenient for us
to to first do the resolution step and
then think about the boolean rule
because it turns out that there are
different boolean rules that you can
apply and saturation is just one of them
we'll talk more about this in a in a
minute
okay fantastic so now we know how to do
conflict analysis also
we're just going to do uh cdcl does
resolution so instead we're going to do
generalized resolution and then maybe do
saturation to get the clause
okay so let's let's do this on a toy
example so here we have two constraints
two x one plus two x two plus two x
three plus x four greater equal
four and two x one bar plus two x two
bar plus two x three bar greater equals
three
now if you think about that this is just
a very convoluted way constraint one is
just saying that the majority of x1 to
x3 should be true
c2 is claiming that actually a majority
should be false
so this is just contradictory and the
our pseudo-boolean solver should be able
to figure this out so let's see what
happens
well we start by setting x1 to false
say and when you set x1 to false
then the slack here will be uh
5 minus 4 that's 1
and that slack 1 is smaller than the
coefficients 2 here
so according to c1 both x2 and x3
propagate to true
note interestingly in contrast to to
conflict-driven clause learning the same
pseudo-boolean constraint can
can propagate multiple times also at
different contexts in the search
this is an interesting difference okay
but now we have a conflict because c2
is unhappy if c if x2 and x3 are both
true then we have a conflict and we have
negative slack here minus 1.
so now what a cdcl resolver would have
done it would have taken the conflict
constraint
2 c2 it would have resolved it with the
reason c1 over this ill-fated
propagation
x3 so let's do that and if you do the
math
and cancel everything out just again we
don't need to do any multiplication
because we're resolving over x3 that has
a 2 here and has a 2 here
so we just sum this up and then do the
cancellation and we get x 4
greater than equal 1.
and then we said we should saturate but
this is already saturated constraint so
nothing happened so
this is not great you know we screwed up
so why did we screw up because we wanted
to maintain the invariant that this
constraint explains what went wrong
when we remove x3 from the trail so when
we remove x3 from the trail we have x1
false and x2 true
but you know x4 doesn't say anything
about this we certainly
it's an interesting fact that apparently
x4 has to be true
and we didn't know this before but it
doesn't explain what we did wrong in our
search because
the solver hasn't even done anything
about x4
okay so this didn't work it crashed
so let me try to explain what went wrong
um so the problem is that the
generalized resolution rule is just
taking a linear combination and that is
sound over the reals
and over the reals if you look at the
propagation given
x1 false and x2 true c1
knows that x3 has to be at least a half
but it's saying if i can just get a half
then i and i could also get the
contribution from x4
then two times a half plus one would
actually be greater
plus that x1 is also sorry x2 is
contributing then i would get four
so over the reels c1 just propagates a
half
and then again over the reels c2 says
that well you know i won't be impossible
i already got uh x1 so if you would just
give
give me half of x3 then i would be happy
so over the reels there is no conflict
and then you do a generalized resolution
step
and eliminate x3 and there's there's
simply no conflict to see
so what should we do about this well we
somehow have to
help the solver syntactically to do
boolean reasoning
and one way of doing this is to try to
make sure
that this constraint would propagate x3
all the way to one also over the reals
equivalently if you think about this
it would be nice to have a recent
constraint where the slack is actually
zero which means that the only way of
satisfying it is that all
literals contribute to the full
how would we do this this is where i'll
intentionally start going
very fast it turns out that
we should use the weakening rule
what's weakening weakening is when you
have a constraint
you take some literal and you say what's
the best that could happen here well l
lj could be true and if so it
contributes aj
but the rest of the constraint still has
to contribute capital
a minus aj so clearly this constraint
implies this constraint but it's a
potentially weaker constraint so that's
why it's known as weakening
so we should take a recent constraint
and we should apply weakening on it to
get a weaker constraint
oh let's observe how could a weaker
constraint
give stronger reasoning well the reason
is that when we're doing weakening
we're forcing the weakening step is
enforcing booleanness
we're weakening by the full amount and
somehow this is turns out
what is needed to work so let me just do
this very quickly
just do the example show what happens
and leave the explanation for the
offline
pre-recorded tutorial so but the the
idea that we have is we can take the
reason constraint
and if the resolvent isn't good if it
isn't conflicting then we weaken on some
non-falsified literal except the one we
want to resolve over because if we
weaken over that literal it's gone and
that would be bad because
then we can't do the resolution step and
then we apply saturation and then we
resolve and hope for the best so let's
try to do that here's our reason
let's weaken it on x2 say we get this
we saturate nothing happens we resolve
again we get this
too bad and this is still not violated
by x1 so this is not violated by x1
false and x2
true unfortunately
okay what can we do well we can try to
weaken even more
let's we can also on x4 so then
if we begin on x2 and x4 we're saying
this could give a contribution two
this could give a contribution one and
the rest then have to give a
contribution
four minus two minus one that's one so
we get two x
one plus two x three greater equal one
after weakening
but now saturation kicks in you see that
there's no reason to have twos here once
is sufficient
this constraint implies this and now
when you do the resolution step
something interesting happens we derive
that
apparently x2 has to be false
and that is actually violated by the
trade so far so now we got an
explanation what did we do wrong well
the mistake that we made
was we assigned x2 to false that was
clearly a mistake we shouldn't have done
that
so now we can learn this constraint we
can
saturate it and then learn it and then
propagate and then it's not so hard to
see that now we will propagate to
contradiction without having made
any decisions and that means
the formula is unsatisfiable so we're
done
okay and so this is
the algorithm and
so we should when we do the resolution
step during conflict analysis
we first try to resolve if the slack is
negative we're happy
then we're maintaining the fact that the
thing we're deriving
on the right hand side in on the
conflict side
is conflicting it's violated but if not
then we find some literal that is not
falsified we weaken on it and we try
again and we do this until we exit this
while loop
and now you have to argue why this works
and
i think for the interest of time and
since i want to
cover other things i won't have time to
really explain to you why it works
but it does work and uh
yeah and the reason is actually that you
could it so what happens we said that
you wanted full
propagation you wanted the reason to
have slack zero you can prove
that at some point during this while
loop you have to have a constraint that
gets like zero
and at that point the conflict analysis
will work if it didn't
earlier again i'm aware that i'm totally
not explaining this well
but
i'll i think i'll leave it at this and
then i see there's a question
that the trailer assigned x1 to 0 not x2
to 0
is there a typo in my slides or i don't
understand this question
so that we learned what we learned here
is that x2
should be false but it was assigned to
true
or are you saying that so so like
we're saying that this
assignment was wrong but then you can
make the fair argument that well
um somehow it was just because of this
decision and that's true but the
constraint is
just saying that
x2 has to be false and then we can just
back jump to top level without any
decisions and propagate this
ah okay so it seems that we figured out
this question
so so um yeah so ryanko could i ask a
question
yeah on your next slide you have the uh
you were choosing literals l prime
does it matter which order you choose
those in excellent question that's
uh like for instance should i choose
one thing you should not you should not
uh choose
um falsified literals because then this
whole argument crashes
but should you choose unassigned
literals or should you choose
literals that are already satisfied
that's a good question
i think there's um
these are these kind of questions where
um
i think there would be much room for for
uh
some more rigorous theoretical
investigation
i think uh so i don't
i don't have this in cash and also with
sleep deprived after having
prepared this tutorial if anyone in my
group like is stefan goht is here and
remembers whether we should weaken on i
think there's
we tend to prefer weakening on either on
unassigned and on
or unsatisfied i don't remember which
one of the top of my head i have to take
that offline but
there's no like rigorous explanation
which one you would prefer
um okay and it could make a difference
you could get different results
depending on the order oh sure i mean
this is a very
conflict analysis is a very syntactic
operation so yes
you can also ask like um yeah there are
lots of questions here in fact
uh you could imagine that you can you
can weaken
actually one thing that works is that
you can weaken away all these literals
in one go and it would again it would
work do you want to do this or do you
want to weaken as little as possible
not clear has not been
rigorously investigated well jacob but
what is not rigorously investigated is
the
the effectiveness but the correctness is
fine no you can
use it correctness correctness is fine
this this
this pseudo pseudocode will always work
no matter which choice
which choice yes correct
this will always work but we will get a
different constraint
yes thank you okay
so if you compare now to conflict-driven
cross-learning here's uh like what
conflict-driven
close learning in the in the cdcl
setting would do and i'm just
illustrating this because there's only
one difference
now that we inserted in the innermost
loop
before like doing the resolution step of
the reason with the conflict side
constraint
we should apply this mysterious
reduction step but other than that
this whole algorithm is exactly what we
have in cvcl
and sort of this is i mean i'm
simplifying a bit but i i
would say essentially this is what set4j
is doing
like this and then saturday i mean cy4j
is an enormously big solver it's doing
tons of stuff but this is sort of what
lies at the heart of the conflict
analysis
okay good so compared to cdcl one
problem is that it's harder to detect
propagation we know
if you attended the cdcl tutorial that
in order to propagate on clauses you
just need to keep track of two literals
that have not yet been assigned
if you know for a clause that there are
two literals that have not been assigned
then you don't care if the clause is of
size 2 or if it's of size 200
you know it's not propagating so you
don't need to watch the whole clause you
just keep two literals
and that's in fact a big secret of uh
how
propagation can be so efficient for a
suitable
constraint this is not true if you look
at this constraint for instance we
clearly have to watch
everything because if you just take any
x i and falsify it then all of the
others will propagate through
and this turns out to be a huge problem
how to do efficient
pseudo boolean propagation in the
conflict analysis that i showed you
we're doing resolution steps
every resolution step potentially does
the least common multiple computation
this means that integers can grow
coefficient sizes explode
if you go to arbitrary precision
arithmetic you can get
really large numbers and the solver
grinds to a hole just because the
arithmetic is so slow and this is a real
problem
an even more serious problem is that if
you're evil
and you take a cnf formula and you write
it as pseudo boolean constraints as
we've seen you can do and feed it
to sudo boolean solver then it will just
run cdcl it will never derive anything
other than clauses
but it will do so paying extra for all
the sophisticated data structures that
it's never using
so if your input is in cnf you should
not run the pseudo boolean solver
that's a terrible idea
at least if you're running this is not
true if you now have an objective
function but if you're just having a
decision problem in cnf
then you should not run the pseudo
boolean solver and this is a fundamental
problem
so in this sense pseudo-boolean solvers
are super sensitive to the input format
okay well but we said we wanted to do
cutting planes
based solving um
so okay so in the chat you're saying
well i could detect
uh pseudo-boolean constraints in the cnf
and rewrite yes
we could have a pre-processing step
that's a very good point but
there is in fact in the state-of-the-art
pseudo boolean solvers
uh it turns out that this is not so easy
to do and and sat4j and roundingside are
not doing it i'm not aware of any other
solver that does this it's true that you
could try to
like go in the opposite direction take
your cnf and rewrite it as a better
pseudo boolean formula
that how to do that efficiently is is an
open research problem this is a
and it's a very interesting research
direction
okay but cutting planes as
in the theory literature is defined with
linear combination and the division rule
where you can divide by
some c everywhere and then just round up
here again the correctness of this rule
depends on me using this normalized form
where everything is positive
and
saturday does what i think is this the
llm paper daniel
because i think it's it's fairly limited
like in general you wouldn't be able to
do this
yeah there's a but i think that's a
limited
um yeah but you wouldn't i don't think
you run it by
default and i don't think you're able to
run i mean there's also a research
version of rounding sat that does it
and that works better i think but still
not good enough to be switched on
like as by default
so i think it's fair to say that how to
do this efficiently
uh without taking a penalty uh is
is an open problem i'd be happy to talk
about it offline i think it's a it's a
challenging
uh problem it's a good problem it's an
obvious way to improve
to improve uh pseudo pseudo-boolean
solvers
okay so cutting planes defined in this
way getting back to division
is in fact an implicationally complete
proof system this means that if i have a
bunch of constraints and they
imply some other constraint then there's
a syntactic
derivation of this constraint and for
if i instead take out this division rule
and plug in the saturation rule that we
saw before that's not an implicationally
complete
proof system so in some sense it seems
to be
weaker maybe so the question is what
happens if i use division
instead of saturation could i get a
stronger conflict analysis
and sort of the short answer is that
yes so let's let's do that and again
i'm being very brief here uh because i
want to focus
on optimization and i want to focus on
open problems i
refer you to the pre-recorded material
for a more detailed overview here
but basically what we want to do here
is when we do the weakening we'll find
non-falsified literals
which have coefficients that are not
divisible by the coefficient
of the propagating literal so here for
c2 x
3 is propagating and
x4 has coefficient 1 which is not
divisible by 2.
so we weaken away x4 and then we divide
by the coefficient of x3
and then we do the resolution step and
boom we have contradiction right away
so for this particular toy example at
least divisions seem to be much much
much better
than saturation
and you can ask if uh if this is a
general
claim or is just this toy example and i
think um
it's more of like it's just this toy
example i i think i'll
get back to this in a minute um
so just to say again so so now we have
another reduction algorithm and again i
refer to the pre-recorded part for the
details but i'm just saying that
so here's what we do we look at the
propagating literal l
we take the coefficient and then one by
one we pick out
literals that have that are not
falsified
and that have a coefficient that is not
divisible
by the coefficient of the propagating
literal we try to weaken and resolve
and we can guarantee that this will in
the end work
and i won't try to do the proof online
you have it in the pre-recorded material
well the proof is here but you have to
think about it
for a second
okay so should you do division or
saturation well i guess daniel libber
and i should have a
discussion about this maybe i don't know
if he wants to comment on this in the
chat so here's
here's here's my take um
in general if you don't know which kind
of problems you're running on
then it seems division is better what we
have seen is that when you have
a formula where pseudo boolean reasoning
doesn't really pay off maybe you
could have basically done cdcl-based
reasoning
then the conflict analysis is faster so
the solar
reasons faster runs faster when you use
division
this changes when the reasoning gets
more sophisticated
then conflict analysis gets much much
slower but it also seems to pay off and
one nice thing compared to using
saturation is that
because you're dividing all the time
this keeps your coefficients small
so you don't have this same explosion
in coefficient size so in fact the
default setting in our rounding sets
always to do fixed precision arithmetic
and then you of course you have to deal
with overflow but that doesn't happen
too often
however to be fair there are some
problems like for instance involving
verification of multiplier circuits
where sat4j is so much better and i
don't know why i wish i understood
well it's better and could do something
about it
so choosing between division and
saturation is not clear that
you know how to choose and we still have
the problem of efficient unit
propagation
even if you use division you still have
the problem that you will degenerate the
resolution and cdcl
if someone is evil and gives you a cnf
and
even if someone is nice and gives you a
nice pseudo-boolean encoding
it can be the case that the problem is
obviously
unsatisfiable it's like blindingly
obviously unsatisfiable because if you
relax it to a linear program it's
infeasible so there are no real
solutions even
and for such a problem instance cutting
planes can
tree light cutting planes can extremely
efficiently prove
unsatisfiability and yet we have
instances where
pseudo boolean solvers run forever they
seem to run for exponential time and we
don't understand why
okay so let me
highlight four slides with with things
that i would like to do to
improve these kind of solvers
uh pre-processing as was mentioned for
cardinality detection so but also for
other reasons pre-processing seems to be
very important for sat solvers
uh on the mixed introduce linear
programming side in mip solvers they
call it pre-solving it's also important
but pseudo boolean solvers don't have
much by way of
pre-processing and i don't know why it
seems like we should borrow
techniques from met or from cdcl and
make them work for pseudo-boolean
solving that would be a
great thing to do one
really big problem what to do with the
stupid cnf format how can
how can we if you get a decision problem
encoded in cnf
how can you leverage the power of
counting planes in particular what about
cardinality constraint detection so what
i'm aware of i am aware of one paper
that i think is what daniel liber was
referring to in the question and answer
um we know
but hopefully i can get corrected in
real time if i say this wrong
so this is like a pre-processing step
where you can try to recover
cardinality constraints the problem is
that it's fairly expensive
especially if it doesn't pay off and you
can only recover like
maybe at least an at most one
constraints
or maybe at least at most two
constraints but for larger k you can't
really do it
we have a version of of our solver
where it's more like an in processing
step you do the detection on the
fly it seems promising but not good
enough to actually be
used in practice so i think dealing with
cnfs
and doing cardinality detection
efficiently and a challenge here
is the challenge is not to come up with
a toy
benchmark where cardinality detection
will pay off the challenge here is to
have it in a solver
silently in the background so that when
it's not needed it doesn't cause a
performance hit
but when it turns out to be needed then
somehow the solver automatically
realizes this and does the right thing
and a general sort of more of an
anecdotal claim
is when you take a cdcl solder it seems
to be fairly robust these days like for
instance you take your cnf formula and
you randomly permute the variables the
clauses maybe the signs of the literals
and most of the time the cdcl solver
doesn't care too much it's like it
performs
the same it's my experience whereas
i mean i'm not making this as a formal
claim it's more of an observation
but for pseudo boolean sorry this is
very much not so they're very
sensitive it seems to these kind of
permutations so i think the solar
technology is like well less well
developed
conflict analysis is a huge area i think
there's room for lots and lots of
research here should you do division
should you do saturation
maybe you should do it adaptively
because apparently there are some
problems where saturation is better
some programs where division are better
or should you use some other boolean
rule entirely there are lots of cut
rules in the integer linear programming
in programming literature what about
those
how can you so there's one
very intriguing phenomenon that i won't
even have time to talk about you have to
read the paper
but there's the issue of
that you can get literals in your
constraint that clearly don't play any
role that are irrelevant
but they can really mess up the mess up
the conflict analysis what do you do
about those
there are lots of degrees of freedom in
how to do the conflict analysis
sometimes you can just skip resolution
steps because the slack is so negative
we already talked about how should you
weaken
how much should you weaken what should
you weaken should you learn a general
pseudo boolean constraint or maybe
actually the the earliest solver galena
said well
you don't need this generality just
round everything to cardinality
constraints
when you learn a so-called asserting
constraint it turns out that it can be
asserting at several different levels
how
do you know where to back jump as far as
possible or as short as possible or
which you do how should you do
with your integer arithmetic
the clause minimization that is being
done in cdcl conflict analysis it would
be nice to get some analog of that we
don't have that
and sort of a general theme with all of
these questions is
how do you know what a good learned
constraint is for instance
if i'm choosing between division and
saturation i could try to do my
conflict analysis step with both i get
two new
constraints out and i can choose the
best one but that
in order to do that i have to see which
one is the best one and you can there
are many parameters
um according to which you can compare
pseudo boolean constraints and it's not
so clear what
what it means that a certain constraint
is better or worse than another one
and from the theory side
these algorithms define proof systems
subsystems
of cutting planes it would be very
interesting to understand these proof
systems better in particular how
division
is related to saturation
[Music]
solar gear sticks that's more like an
applied area
um i'm running a little bit behind so
i'll be brief but basically
most of the heuristics are just copied
from cdcl
but again there are lots of more degrees
of freedom so you can think about maybe
you should
design things slightly differently this
should be investigated there's a
wonderful
phd thesis just defended by roman valon
in lance highly recommended reading he's
investigated
some of these questions but there's
really room for much more work here
also some of the latest news over on the
sat side
like these different modes for sat
focused for
search and unsat focused search or
different phases for face saving one
thing that i forgot to mention here is
chronological backtracking for instance
all of these things that seem to be
really really valuable for sat solvers
that just haven't been coded up in
pseudo-boolean solvers
it would be very interesting to do this
and see what pays off what doesn't pay
off i think there's lots of room for
just
for for engineering work and then
running experiments evaluating trying to
understand and to improve
state-of-the-art in pseudo-boolean
solving and lots and lots of obvious
research directions
again efficient unit propagation there's
room for improvement there
even during during conflict analysis to
decide whether you have
a certain constraint sort of a unique
implication point constraint
is much more difficult than in cdcl
and then a shameless self-plug i mean
for sat solvers we have proof vlogging
what about sudo boolean solvers
shouldn't we have proof logging so that
you can know that the pseudo boolean
solver is correct this is something that
i've been working a lot on together with
my student stefan goff
and some collaborators in glasgow and
elsewhere um so
but this is not the topic of this talk
so this brings us now to
yes well i mentioned if you would like
to take a five minute break
yeah that's what i'm thinking about that
this might this might be a good place
because now we talked about decision
problems and we want to move into
optimization
so yeah why don't we take a five minute
break
here sounds like a good idea so we'll
start back promptly at
uh 32 past the hour or
two past the hour depending on what time
time time zone you're on in five minutes
okay thank you okay and as part of five
minutes uh there's a
question from from victor about is your
bibliography available
ah uh the answer is yes
um let's see um so i think simons
actually have the the slides online
there are some typos on the simon's
website that i think i corrected
let's see if i can whoops what's this
what happened now
i wanted to do something what happened
[Music]
um
a lot of a lot of effort went into the
bibliography so i'm very happy that
someone
is asking about this um so what you
can do is
let's see if you go to my web page which
for some reason still resides at
kth don't ask i think if you google for
jakob nordstrom research you should end
up somewhere here
and then you
blow it up a bit and then you click on
some presentations
and here you have the slides for the
live talk
and then some bug fixed slides for the
tutorial
um so basically if you if you find my my
webpage you should be able to take it
from there
there's a there's a link in the chat
window for the tutorial slides
yeah that's good great thanks for that
so just just a small cabinet that there
are some typos in those slides
that you have been corrected in the
version that you see on your screen now
but i'll try to update the simon's
version also this
i can also issue my own shameless plug
that yakub and i have
a proof complexity survey article which
probably also contains many of these
citations but but maybe not quite all
right so you should definitely get the
handbook of satisfiability and
and and drop everything else and and
move on to chapter seven
uh which i think what we covered so far
is
is developed fairly well there in
chapter seven more so i think than in
the actual chapter on pseudo-boolean
solving
um what will follow now in the second
half
is not in that chapter though but but
you're right so many of the
many of the references so far and many
more references are in that set handle
and as it happens i mean there's also
well so this survey paper you can find
on sam's webpage obviously you can also
find it
among my survey papers let's see like
where is it
ah here i guess this thing
so this should be something that is very
close to the
published version
i think the only difference is that
maybe we added an abstract here that
wasn't after this but otherwise i think
that nothing in the actual text changed
so that's also highly recommended
reading and containing more references
even then
than in this talk
[Music]
if there are any other questions i'm
happy to take them i'm sort of going a
bit
fast maybe but that's because i want to
talk about so much and also you have it
pre-recorded if you really want to i
mean that friends
in particular if you want to go into the
details of
sudobu and conflict analysis i tried to
do that fairly carefully in the video i
only realized
afterwards that that chunk of the video
part two of the video is something like
two hours which is
horrible of course but that's because
i'm doing all of this very slowly and
i'm also discussing
other possible pseudo-boolean rules that
have been considered
like the strengthening is something that
is apparently done in
operations research that would also it's
an interesting rule because it would
recover cardinality constraints
but again it doesn't seem to fly in
practice
and i discuss lots of other things there
in
so part two of the pre-recorded tutorial
okay so that's been the break so let's
hope everyone's back
and uh we can continue and then whenever
you're ready
good so what we did so far it was we
defined the problem
and we talked about pseudo boolean
solving so there we just had a
um a pseudo boolean formula we wanted to
determine satisfiability
or feasibility now what we're going to
do is we're going to add
an optimization function an objective
function
and we want to find the solution
minimizing this
okay and this is very very related to
max at in some sense max sat and
pseudo-boolean optimization is more or
less the same thing
so let me explain this so the weighted
partial max that problem is you have a
cnf with some soft clauses c1 to cm
that come with weights and let's maybe
let's have integral weights just for
simplicity rather than real valued
weights
and then you have some hard clauses and
your task is to find
a solution an assignment that has to
satisfy all the hard clauses and it's
more interesting usually to assume that
actually this
hard part of the formula is satisfiable
so you can find such an assignment
and then you want to maximize the amount
of soft clauses satisfied so you want to
maximize
some of the weights of the soft
satisfied clauses
except that now we're going to do this
classic switch of perspective
which you always do when you have a max
attack you immediately think about the
minimization problem so max out is a
minimization problem namely
minimize the penalty of the falsified
soft clauses
and let's write a clause c sub v
for a clause c with the weight w and
the hard constraints have infinite
weight so that means that you can't
afford
to falsify them because then your your
objective function will have value
infinity that's bad
if you're looking for a minimization
okay
so here's like an example max at
instance and the point is you realize
that it's fairly easy to rewrite this
into a pseudo boolean optimization
instance but you just take all the soft
clauses
and for every soft clause you add a new
variable which you can use to satisfy
this clause but you don't want to do
that
you'd rather satisfy the clause itself
so what you're minimizing
is how many of these variables
you're using and the coefficients are
exactly the weights
of the soft clauses so it should be
hopefully clear that this is
the same problem and this is sometimes
referred to as the blocking variable
transformation the b's or the blocking
variables or the relaxation variables so
just to make sure we're on the same page
here you can satisfy everything except
this clause
so the penalty of the optimal solution
is is three
which is by this assignment you can also
go in the other direction
to take a general pseudo boolean
optimization problem and translate it
into maxsat except that it will be max
sat with
potentially pseudo-boolean constraints
instead of clauses and if you want to be
formal this is known as a weighted
boolean optimization problem
if your constraints are not clauses but
pseudo boolean constraints
and the way to do this is here is my
pseudo boolean optimization instance
i keep all my constraints i make them
into hard constraints
and then every literal in the objective
function i negate it and i make it into
a soft clause
with the weight being the coefficient
and now it should be clear that
an optimal max at solution here is
indeed minimizing this objective
so this is the same problem and the
reason why this is relevant is that it
seems
that there's more development going on
over on the max ad solving side than on
the pseudo-boolean side
so what i'm going to talk about now
different solver
solving approaches i i think are most
well developed in
on the mac sat side so i'll try to
explain them in in pseudo-boolean
language
i want to talk about linear search uh
core guided search
and the implicit hitting set approach
let's see
and and and yeah so again they come from
max
at where these literals would be these
blocking variables of soft clauses but
we don't need that so we'll just think
of a general
uh linear objective that we want to
minimize okay linear search is easy what
you do is you just solve the problem
when you find the solution you add a new
constraint saying i want a better
solution then start over
until you get unsatisfiable and then you
know you're done
okay so let's do a toy example i hope
this is clear but just to make sure
so here's a some formula that i'm not
telling you what it is the objective
x1 plus 2x2 plus all the way up to 5x5
plus 6x6
you run the solver it gives the
assignment x four x five equals one
all the other false so that gives
subjective value nine
so then i add a constraint saying that i
want
at most eight and i run the solver again
and it finds a new solution say and here
it says
x2 and x4 to true and all the other two
false now i get objective value
six so then i say give me a solution
with
five or better and then the solver says
unset say and then we can safely return
six as the optimal value of this program
it should hopefully be
clear and now if you're a theoretician
say aha but
i've heard that binary search is so much
better than linear search do we do
binary search
and it appears that no we shouldn't
um for
as far as i understand for two reasons
the reason
linear search is bad in theory is that
you could get very small decreases but
you don't
get very small decreases you tend to get
large decreases large jumps
and then all of these solver calls to
the solar oracle are not created equal
because some of them
will be for unsatisfiable instances when
you're looking for a solution that is
too good to be true and some of them
will be for satisfiable instances where
you just want to improve your solution
and it is possible to improve
and it tends to be the case that sad
calls are much much
cheaper than onset calls so doing a
large number of
sat calls during your linear search and
you know that only the final call will
be onset
whereas if you do binary search then you
could potentially do a lot of expensive
onset calls
another reason why
linear search is nice is that you get a
solution quickly even if it's not the
optimal one
once the solar has returned the first
time you have something and there's a
special
actually track in the max at competition
for any time solvers where you really
care about
time is limited and the best solution as
soon as possible is nice and then if you
have a few more extra minutes and you
can
improve your solution great but the
there might be a timeout at any point in
time and then give me the best you have
and it has been argued that in a lot of
applied settings
this any time solving scenario is
actually what you care about
but if you do care about optimality
a sad aspect of linear search is that
until you do this final onset call you
have no idea how good your solution is
you just know that you're finding new
solutions
good so what is core guided search
it takes the opposite approach and it
says
let's assume that we can achieve an
amazing
optimization value in fact let's assume
that we can achieve the optimal value
zero again remember that we're
normalized here everything is positive
so clearly zero is the best you can hope
for
so in corrugated search you say i think
zero that's doable
and you run your pseudo boolean solver
with these
assumptions so running a solver with
assumptions is that you give it some
pre-made decisions that it should apply
before it starts its own search
and when you run the solver with
assumption one or two things can happen
either it says sat and then it means it
found a solution that is consistent with
your assumptions
and then clearly this is an optimal
solution because you you're making the
widely optimistic assumption and it paid
off there was such a solution
now if the solver is run with
assumptions and the assumptions are
inconsistent then it will
return some constraint that explains
why these assumptions are not possible
and in
this context we for instance can learn
some constraint maybe a clause maybe a
more general cardinality constraint
saying that no
out of the k first assumption say at
least a of them have to be true you
can't assume all of them to false
and then what a core guided solver does
it says aha
so let me then i know that the sum of
this expression
is somewhere between a and k but i don't
know where
so let's introduce new variables for
this z
a plus 1 up to z k and let's just impose
i can certainly add a new constraint
saying that sum of
l 1 up to l k is equal to a which is
this lower bound
plus summing from a1 to k these new
variables that j
these edges are new variables now these
are extension values
and once i have this this is inequality
i can go back to my objective function
and rewrite it
and when i replace some multiple of this
with some multiple of this then i'll get
a constant term
update which updates the best possible
lower bound
and now i have a rewritten objective
function and then i run my core guided
solver again
okay so let me do a toy example here
with
with a caveat that i'm again
intentionally going
somewhat fast but i just want to to
convey
the the gist of the core guided idea
like how would this work let's do the
same
toy example so here's our objective
function that we want to minimize again
and we say i believe zero is the correct
value
so we set everything to zero and we run
the solver with these assumptions
and the solver says nope and then it
will return
some kind of constraint it might be a
general pseudo boolean constraint and
i'll
refer to this inspired by
max set terminology let's call this a
core constraint now
in in a max set setting these guys
would actually be blocking variables for
clauses
so this would be a subset of clauses
that cannot all be satisfied at the same
time
that's why it's known as a core but in
our setting
we just have an objective function but
let's call it the core constraint anyway
because it's like
what it would be called if we were doing
a max at instance
so for reasons that i don't have time to
go into this this kind of looks
complicated let's let's
round it to a cardinality constraint in
particular if this is true
the only way that this constraint can be
true is that at least two of the
variables are true
so let me write this let me derive the
best possible cardinality constraint
from this here it is
and now let me do this rewriting i know
that the sum of these four variables is
between two and four
so let me introduce two new fresh
variables y3 and y4
and add constraints pseudo boolean
constraints
so this is syntactic sugar for two
less than equal and a greater than equal
i write them down
saying that the sum of these four
variables is at least two
and then plus y three plus y four i
specify that i want y
three to be greater than y four greater
or equal
and if you think about that this exactly
enforces
the meaning of y sub j
as the sum of these four variables is at
least j
and now what i can do let's look at the
objective function
and i try i want to replace the left
hand side with the right hand side so
let's look at the coefficients
2 3 4 5 i can multiply this whole
equality by 2
and then i can substitute 2 times this
thingy by 2 times this thingy
okay let's do that let's see what
happens so then i get
x2 cancels x3 went down from three to
one x4 went down from four to two
x5 went down from five to three i didn't
touch x6 i didn't touch
x1 and now i added y3 and y4 and a
constant term
4 that shows that i've derived that the
best possible value
wasn't 0 it's maybe 4.
now what do i do well you know let's
stay optimistic
and say well i believe four is the best
possible value so i set
all of these guys including the new guys
to zero and i run the solver again
and now the solver again thinks that
these assumptions are inconsistent and
let's say it returns
this core constraint now this is already
a clause this is already a cardinality
constraint so i don't need to do any
rewriting
so the sum of this is somewhere between
one and four so i introduce now
three new fresh variables and add
pseudo boolean constraints saying that
this sum is equal to this sum
and i want z2 to be greater equals z3
greater equals z4 and if i add these
constraints
to the solver which i can do i mean it's
a free country i can do this
uh then zj will have the meaning
that j will actually encode exactly
the truth value of this variable will be
the truth value of this constraint
okay and now again what i'll do i have
this new equality
it is an equality so i can rewrite my
objective function to something
equivalent
and now let's look at the coefficients
here x4 has a 2
x5 has a 3 x6 has a 6 y3 has a 2.
so i can multiply this whole equality by
2 and replace these guys
by these guys then x4 will cancel
and y3 will cancel and i will get let's
see what i will get
something like this and the point is
that
with the added constraints the value of
this objective function
is the same as the value of this
subjective function
is the same as the value of this
original objective function because i
have pseudo-boolean constraints
enforcing
the equivalence so now i run the pseudo
boolean solver again
and now we know since we had the same
problem when we did linear search we
actually found the solution of value six
so the core guided solver should also
find this
and indeed it says that yep i could
actually find an assignment with all of
these guys to zero
and then i know that my optimal value is
six and i can also from the solution i
can read off
the original values if i care about it
if i want to reconstruct the solution
so this is like a crash course in core
guided optimization
this is how it works
okay so what's nice with this well that
we get lower bounds quickly
and that helps us to cut off parts of
the search space
but of course i don't know anything
about the solution until
the final call again i'm sort of doing
linear search but in the other direction
and again i don't have any estimate of
how good my lower bound is
so somehow it would be nice to do some
combination of linear search
and core guided search and this you can
do in in various ways
one thing you can do is called weight
stratification where you assume
not everything in the objective function
to true you focus on the coefficients
with largest weights
and run with those assumptions and then
either
it turns out that this is inconsistent
and then you get a core
contest consisting of much fewer
assumptions so it's more compact core
or if it turned out that i could assume
these heavyweight literals
to false then you found a decent
solution already
so this is like interpolating between
linear search and correlated search
there are other things you can do that i
don't have time about
you can get independent core if you get
a core constraint over say the first k
literals
then repeat your assumption again but
omit this guys and then you'll find if
there's any other core that is
independent
and then when you do the update uh for
the lower bound of the objective
functions
all these independent cores that are
disjoint will will contribute
independently to the objective function
update
one thing you can do is you can i said
that core guided search was good at
cutting off the search base well so
run it in the beginning for a while and
then switch to linear search
once you've gotten a good enough lower
bound estimates
or um do full hybrid search switching
back and forth between core guided and
linear search
now to the best of my understanding max
out solvers don't really do this so much
and i
think the reason for this is that the
way i've described it with these
cardinality constraints if you're in a
mac sat setting
you would need to do a lot of rewriting
to cnf when you do this
but the nice thing with being in a
pseudo boolean setting is that all these
equalities that i wrote down there are
actually they are what the pseudo
boolean solver is operating with so it's
all native
it's all very cheap and you can do cheap
hybrid interleaving search
there are other things that we don't
know how to do in a pseudo boolean
setting the core minimization
which is somehow analog of of minimizing
your learned clauses
uh one thing that i don't have time to
talk about really is is
doing lazy variable introduction for
instance here you see we
uh introduced
three new variables in one go turns out
that you will have lots of new variables
maybe you can be lazy and just introduce
z2
first with this meaning and then you
introduce
z3 and z4 later if they're needed turns
out that this can sometimes be important
um one um here's a these are all like
applied questions here's a theory
question
uh why is core added search good and how
good is it
note that the interesting thing is that
now correlated search
pseudo boolean search is actually
cutting planes with extension variables
and now theoreticians of course know
that already resolution with extension
variables that's extended friggin
that's extremely powerful and now here
we're doing extended cutting planes
so why haven't people on the plied side
been doing
proof systems with extension variables
well i think the reason is because it's
hard to know
to have good heuristics for which
variables to extend but here
the search is suggesting to us what
might be good extension variables
namely extension variables that explain
why we can't get the objective value
that we were shooting for
so i think a very interesting uh
theoretical question would be can you
somehow characterize
what is the power of cutting planes with
this limited form of extension how good
is it
how good can it be can we prove some
upper bounds some lower bounds
because it turns out in practice this
can be really powerful
uh and let me just show you um so we
actually implemented this
in rounding sat
and here's the hybrid version
interleaving
corrugated search and linear search and
if you compare
to just doing linear search or just
doing core guided search
then most of the time you get a fairly
significant
improvement this thing i talked about
lazy variables if you have knapsack
constraints with a lot of different
coefficients
you can see that uh
here you have here you're not being lazy
here you are being lazy a fairly
significant
difference in the number of of
benchmarks you solve
um also we have some crafted tricky
benchmarks for cutting planes
these core guided techniques really pay
off except for the very annoying
last line of this table which is the
academic mips over skip
that has the rudeness of beating
us on all of these instances so that's
why i also want to talk a little bit
about
mip solving before we end um
but it's again sort of
then there was a question do i apply sub
problem optimization
in my hybrid approach i don't know what
sub
problem optimization is so i don't think
i apply it i mean we just
uh we just run this basically run the
algorithm that i described
core guided search and then we switch to
linear search and then we switch back
and i think yeah i think there's like
lots of things that you could probably
do to improve this
so this is just a first proof of concept
of
proof of concept implementation but it
shows there's really promise
um i'll be happy to talk about wpm2 and
wpm3
offline um so i don't
know i have to admit uh
exactly what they do so i definitely
think there's room for improvement
um so this is more like and i think this
is a
like this whole talk is is not in order
to um
i'm giving this talk not in order to
tell you about the beauty of a
well-developed technology
of solvers it's rather you know i'm
trying to my sales pitch
is that there's so much that should be
possible to do here in pseudo boolean
solving borrowing from
from max out borrowing from mip solving
borrowing from sat solving
uh i think there's lots of low hanging
fruit here
but i think also one advantage of the
pseudo boolean setting is really that
you have these zero one integer linear
inequalities
that you have the powerful cutting
planes based reasoning i think
um this can really pay off
another question jacob yes this
keep you you said it very fast and i
didn't get it so it beats everyone
and what happens with it it's it's not
see the brilliance
or based or what it's a mixed integer
linear programming solver
ah so it's another technology
okay but it
i mean based on this it's a technology
that maybe we should learn more about no
that's what they're going to say i mean
if it's a different technology and it
beats everyone
then yeah that's that's why there's a
fourth part to this tutorial
okay we're getting there uh
let's see before we get there
can i briefly describe the problem sets
if
in the interest of time uh
no but if you i mean you have the
reference there
this is the constraints paper it's on my
webpage uh i'd be happy to shoot me an
email i'd be happy to talk about it
offline
i think i won't do it here um oh okay so
i guess here i can say very briefly
uh actually this is the latest pseudo
boolean competition
optimization problems uh with limited
precision
these are some zero one intro linear
programs from the mip competition
uh this is a collection of challenging
knapsack problems
these are uh our own problems inspired
by the proof complexity literature
it's like a set that we've been building
accumulating over
a number of years with the nice thing
with crafted instances that
you can design them so that they're hard
in different ways like you need
dag-like reasoning with learning or you
need cutting planes based reasoning
or you need parity reasoning or and then
you stress test the solvers in different
ways to see if they can figure this out
and definitely yes so for for knapsack
it's
uh so one thing that i think is is um
so i was going to move on but victor is
tricking me into commenting more
but he's making a good comment that that
mib solver have been working on on
knapsack problems so it's not surprising
that they're good yes and they have
dedicated techniques so that's another
thing in mip solving there's a lot of
pre-processing going on
so skip for instance realizes it does
some analysis and then it says oh
i have a knapsack problem why don't i
try to drive
dynamic programming just because i see
it's an abstract problem
and this is something that somehow the
sat solving philosophy and the suitable
installing philosophy is
i have this specification it is just a
syntactic
object it's whatever let's run my
general purpose algorithm on it
so this is not how map solvers work i
think they're more like they're really
trying to analyze the structure
especially
the commercial solvers have like tons
and tons of i mean they've seen
all of these problems out there in
industry and they're trying to pull all
kinds of crazy tricks
and since they're closed source you
don't even know maybe what they're doing
yeah so yeah yeah so in that sense i
mean i
i think one you know
the positive spin on this is to say well
there's an immense amount of work that
has gone into
mip-solving development and here you
have a small research team just hacking
away for like half a year
and we get this close right that somehow
seems that
that there's promise in this technology
that would be my my
positive spin on this uh just to add to
what you said yakub
about mip solvers uh smt solvers tend to
have a similar flavor
in that you know you study analyze
problem domains and
add uh heuristics that are
they detect some pattern and they you
you add heuristics appropriately
uh for example rewrite rules and so on
and so forth
right yes and we're going to have a talk
on on uh
satisfiability modulo series on smt
solving tomorrow i think
correct although it's it's a brief talk
and and then we have a an impolite
constraint programming person suggesting
in the chat that we should move away
from cnf as our problem format and use
more expressive formulas for
for describing our problems to which i
have to
reply to kieran mccreesh that he should
be polite when we invite them to a sat
workshop i think and not complain
right um no that's a good point i mean
you can you can take a different view on
this uh that we can
model problems differently and i guess
that's that's already one of the reasons
why you would want to do pseudo-boolean
solving
rather than than cnf
is precisely because the pseudo-boolean
modeling language is nicer
for instance counting constraints you
can model them in a nicer way but you
can certainly
you can go further and and do general
constraint programming where you have a
much richer language
and in fact this is something that i
would also like to do i don't have time
to talk about it but
because even even in constraint
programming you have this concept
of of conflict analysis and learning
constraints although they call them no
goods
uh and i think there is room for
borrowing
from from sat based conflict analysis
and pseudo boolean conflict analysis and
you could potentially
plug it into constraint programming
solvers
so but you could also like one other way
of it turns out that
sort of one once the sat solver is good
enough i think the reason why sat is
successful is that you don't need to try
to detect something the solver is just
somehow good enough to do it
automatically and i think that's
would be one goal for pseudo boolean
solving also that some of the underlying
solving technology is so strong
that i you don't need to tell me that
it's a knapsack constraint because
whatever i do with my cuts
is like automatically doing the right
thing that would be the vision i think
anyway we're running
badly late on time so let's see
oh i haven't even talked about the
implicit thing so that's bad let me very
quickly talk about the implicit hitting
set approach
so again we have this minimization
problem given a bunch of constraints
let's think of them as clauses now
then we again run the solver with
assumptions but we
collect all these core clauses that have
to be satisfied
and then we know that whatever
assignment we have
that to minimize this will have to
satisfy all of these
and then what we can do we can try to
pick out
a cheap as set of literals as possible
that will hit all of these clauses
because we know we have to do this so we
want to compute the hitting set
and what we do is we run the solver we
collect cores
and in every iteration we compute the
hitting set because we know we need to
satisfy these
these clauses somehow but we compute the
cheapest possible hitting set
and then we run the solver with the
assumption saying that well these
literals and the hitting set they're
true the rest is false
and if we found the solution since we're
having an optimal hitting set we know
that we're optimal and otherwise we got
a new core
and we add it to our set of course and
compute the new hitting set and and
repeat
okay i'm doing this a bit quickly
because i want to move on to mip solving
the interesting thing is that implicit
hitting certain coordinated approaches
seem to be orthogonal sometimes
implicit sitting set is better sometimes
corregated is better
we don't have any theory on this so
here's a call to the theoreticians
model implicit heating set algorithms
model corrugated algorithms try to prove
simulation or separation results for the
corresponding proof systems
there's some work on this i think sam
bus for instance has been involved in
something like this this is i think a
paper by
you will feel muslim mark venials and
others so there's some work in the
direction i think there's room for for
much more
um or if
they have complementary strengths why
not combine implicit hitting set
and query added search so in the max app
community there i think there was a
solver
last year that did this with some
success or why don't we combine implicit
in things that would suitably
optimization so then you're not looking
for
the reason you are happy with hitting
sets is that for a clause you know you
only need to hit one literal
and then the clause will be happy in
general if these are pseudo boolean
constraints
you want to find like a minimum cost
partial assignment that is guaranteed to
satisfy all of these constraints
it would be interesting to implement
this i don't think anyone has done it
good still something like
a little bit more than 25 minutes to
talk about mixed into the linear program
um so here it is a mixed interlinear
program we're minimizing
say a i x i subject to a bunch of
constraints
and i guess me people seem to like less
than
equal better than greater than equal so
i switch now from my normalized form to
some mip form in general
some of these variables will be integer
valued some of them will be real valued
now if there are no real valued
variables then we have an integer linear
program
if in addition all uh variables are
bounded between zero and one then we
have a zero one integer linear program
also known as a pseudo-boolean function
this is exactly the same problem
and if in addition we add a vacuous
objective then we just have a
pseudo-boolean
solving problem and we can do this and
in fact it turns out that
for for um decision problems
for some classes of decision problems
pseudo-boolean solving technology is
in fact competitive with the best mib
solvers
and if you choose evil benchmarks then
we're even better
but somehow that the what's
mip really shines where mip really
shines is when you have an objective
function that you can use to somehow
drive a search and then it's very hard
to
even it's hard to come up with even
crafted benchmarks where sudo boolean
solders are better than bib solvers it
can be
done i think but they're like it's hard
really hard to think so map solvers are
good
one difference compared two differences
compared to the
sat community in the pseudo boolean
community is that the best solvers over
on the mips side are closed source
industrial solvers
so that's problematic when you want to
evaluate because it's hard to know what
c
plex gurubian express are doing you
don't have access to the code
you can run the solver like skip instead
and you can look at the code
see what it's doing and it's a very good
solver as we saw
good enough to beat all our
pseudo-boolean solvers but
in general these commercial solvers are
even better another philosophical
difference
is if you're a building a sat or pseudo
boolean solvers then you want to do your
search
you want to be dumb but fast you do fast
decisions
fast propagations and then once you hit
a conflict you back up
you slow down you think carefully about
how to do the conflict analysis
mip is like in some sense the opposite
philosophy
you can spend a ridiculous amount of
effort on making your decisions like
should i decide on this variable
should i decide on that variable
actually maybe let's do some re
some computation on all possible
variables that i could decide on to
really
get a good foundation for making this
momentous decision on what
i'm going to decide on next okay so you
make sure that you make high quality
decisions
so that once it's time to backtrack you
just backtrack
more or less or this is you know i'm not
this is my like
personal bias take on mipsouling i
should say that this is the part of the
tutorial which i know
least about so it's more like my my bias
take on
on mip solving as a computational
complexity theorists and as a
pseudo-boolean and set-solving person
so what do mips always do well they do
some pre-processing though they call it
pre-solving then they do a lot of linear
programming in branch and bound we'll
talk about that
they also use cutting planes the cutting
planes method and one
thing that you have to be careful about
is that when you talk about cutting
planes and cutting planes method and
coming plane's proof system a mid person
will not
understand you because they use the
same terminology but it means something
slightly different
so you have to be really really careful
um just a heads up on this
and then there are lots of heuristics
that i won't have time to talk about
i'll just talk about branch and bound
and branching cut
and refer you to the pre-recorded
tutorial for the other stuff or rather
to the further references that are
provided in the pre-recorded tutorial
so the most important technique is to
relax your problem
so some of these variables are integer
valued let's think of everything as real
valued
now we just have a linear program solve
it
this can be done in polynomial time and
clearly the solution gives at least a
lower bound or if we're super lucky
and it's actually an integral solution
then you're done then you clearly have
the optimal solution
an interesting thing is that i said you
can solve this in in in polynomial time
but you don't use these guaranteed
polynomial time algorithms like
ellipsoid or something you actually use
the simplex algorithm
as far as i understand and the reason
for this is that we will have lots and
lots and lots
of lp calls on related problems and it's
really valuable to
start off where you left off last and
then do a few more pupils
and do something that's called hot
restarts and this is supported by
simplex but not by
these other algorithms
so branch and bound is then you
choose some variable in some smart way
and some bound
and then you solve two sub problems x j
greater than this bound or smaller equal
than this bound minus one
and then you do this recursively and you
grow your
branch and bound tree of subproblems
importantly
uh like what a sat solver do it would go
depth first here but you don't do
that first like one aspect of mipsearch
is that you grow your tree in different
directions at different times depending
on what seems best
and then you can prune your tree for
instance when the lp
is infeasible then you definitely know
that there are no solutions there
or when you solve a problem um the
lp solution is already larger than the
best solutions you have so far your
incumbent solution then you know you
don't need to search in that subject
you can branch on variables but in fact
you can and i think to some
limited extent you do branch on more
general linear expressions
now this is very interesting because
from a theoretical point of view this is
very powerful
if you're branching on arbitrary linear
constraints this is what's known as the
stabbing plane's proof system
which is exponentially stronger than
cutting planes
so so mip solvers are sort of inside
stabbing planes but they're not fully
exploiting stabbing planes this
is my take on this as a theory person
okay so what's a cutting plane method
well
it's once you solve the lp relaxation
and again you've got a solution and if
it's feasible then it's great you can
terminate
but if it's not if it's it's a it's a
fractional solution
[Music]
uh
um then um
so okay so there's stopping planes in
california am i am i understand well
okay wait don't we have any separation
like morally speaking can't you cook up
something that is
i mean okay we don't i thought we had
some cutting plants instances which are
provably hard that are easy for stopping
planes but i guess it was the problem
that cutting planes can then do them in
polynomial size or something um
okay i stand corrected let me rephrase
this to maybe that i think it's
reasonable to believe that stabbing
planes is exponentially more powerful
though this is one of these things that
we theoreticians cannot yet prove but i
think we believe it
isn't that fair to say robert noah would
you subscribe to that
anyway so back to the
cutting plane method what you do when
you have this solution
you can add some new constraint that you
derive in some way
[Music]
that is valid for your original
original problem but has the property
that it's violated by the solution that
you found so you're tightening your
polytope and you're removing this
solution that you're not interested in
and then you just repeat so this is the
cutting plane method
in speak and in this
sense these rules that we saw before the
division rule and the saturation rule
are kind of
sort of cut rules actually
so branch and cut is when you run branch
and bound
but in every subproblem that you have
you also
you repeatedly solve lp relaxation add a
cut resolve add a cut and then some
heuristic for how much you should do
this
and this is i think what lies at the
heart of what makes solvers do
here's another very intriguing cut that
i would like to understand better the
mixed integer rounding cut
and i'm writing it in a pseudo boolean
way
so here's a pseudo boolean normalized
constraint these are literals
everything is non-negative here and
we're having a divisor d
and then we can the mirror cut will
produce this beautiful looking
expression
okay let me not even try to parse what
this is let me just show you
by example what this is and why it might
be interesting so if you have this
constraint
x plus 2y plus 3z plus 4w plus 5u
greater equal 5 then unless i screwed up
the mere cut
yields x plus 2y plus 2z
plus three w plus four u greater or
equal to four
okay so why should we care about this
well one reason to care is
you see that these coefficients all went
down by one
so potentially you could lose three here
right
but the mere cut says no you're only
losing one
on the degree of falsity and you can
compare this to
if you divide instead then it's very
hard to divide
5 to get 4 but if you divide by 3 then
you'd get
5 divided by 3 rounded up is 2 here so
let's divide and then multiply by
2 to get a comparable constraint and
again unless i screwed up
like classic tcs division gives you 2x
plus 2y plus 2z
plus 4w plus 4u greater or equal to 4.
which is clearly a worse constraint the
degree of falsity is the same
but the coefficients here are larger
than these so this is a weaker
constraint than this one
and i think it can be formalized
that the mere cut is like always at
least as good
as division but it can be better how
much better
excellent question i would like to know
i don't
know if there's anything about this in
the literature it seems that
it's a very natural question for me as a
complexity series but it seems like the
mip community hasn't
really studied these questions or maybe
i haven't read the right papers but i
think a very interesting question is
like
mathematically formally pin down
the relative strength of of mere cuts
and and classic division
one issue with mip solvers is that
they're using floating point
and this can lead to rounding errors and
do lead to
rounding errors so it's like a
well-known secret that
commercial map solvers sometimes give
the wrong answers
you just hope that it's not when it's
running on your problem or
you hope that it doesn't matter too much
you can do exact mip solving but it's
much slower and you don't have full
support for all techniques
this brings us to the question of proof
logging which is then not available for
mip solvers
uh despite the fact that again it's so
my understanding that it is well known
it's even well known like what kind of
problems you should feed to say c plex
and girl b
to get high probability of a wrong
answer
it's just that it doesn't seem to happen
often enough
for people to really care about it um
some
there has been some work on proof
logging in particular the group behind
skip
in berlin has been working on this but
proof logging seems
hard i think this is another interesting
question like how would you and it's
hard
because there's a the reason one reason
i think why why proof logging for cdcl
is doable
is that it's a monoculture you only have
cdcl if you can do proof logging for
cdcl then you're golden
but in map solvers they do a lot of
different things it's not even clear
what is a convenient proof format
and also how would you generate these
proofs with low
overhead
let me try to highlight some nice
questions uh
exploit the power of stabbing planes can
we develop better branching heuristics
um i'll talk a bit more the conflict
analysis mip solvers are doing conflict
analysis but they're really just doing
cdcl conflict analysis so they're losing
out exponentially compared to suitable
and conflict analysis
i think suitable and conflict analysis
should be integrated in mip solvers
someone should do this another
interesting
contrast to the sat community is that
you have this parallel development of
sat solving and proof complexity
where a proof complexity somehow
provides theoretical upper and lower
bounds on what set soldiers can do
it seems that you don't have anything
like this in mip
you don't have these families of crafted
benchmarks for which you can make
precise theoretical statements
um so it would be nice to have this
um and then it's mentioned in the chat
yeah i was vaguely aware of this i
didn't
have uh i have to admit i failed to
update
the references there is a recent paper
by gleichner at all
from 2021 a computational status update
for exact rational
mixed integer programming which is
probably a good first paper to read on
this topic
another interesting question which leads
me to the final topic here is
since these meep solvers seems to be so
good maybe we can
steal the best ideas from them and
improve our pseudo-boolean solvers
so what would be the idea well pseudo
boolean solvers are really good at
conflict analysis
but they're lousy at figuring out when
lp relaxations are infeasible
mixed interlinear programs holders are
really good at this they
eat lp relaxation for breakfast they
have lots of interesting cuts but their
conflict analysis is not so great so
why don't we merge the two and we'll get
the best of both worlds
that's the idea
and i just want to tell you about
something that we did
not because it's the final word but
precisely because i think it shows that
there's promise in this direction
but we really don't know how to do it so
this is an invitation to work on this
problem
uh and since i'm coming from the sudobu
and on sat side i will think of the
pseudo boolean solver as being in charge
but it can sort of consult an lp solver
just like
or a mip solver just like would be done
in the mip setting
you could also imagine like having the
mip solver in charge and being able to
consult the pseudo boolean solver for
conflict analysis for instance that
would also be an interesting direction
but i won't talk about this here
so if you want to have a pseudo boolean
solver using an lp solver
the problem is how are you going to do
this just you could just try to use it
as a preprocessor but that won't be
enough
because there are benchmarks that are in
fact with
which have feasible lp relaxations but
infeasibility will occur
quickly once you start searching but not
at the outset
the other extreme doing like a mip
solver we do solve an lp
relaxation before every decision that's
just not feasible because it's a
different order of magnitude
from what the pb solver would do so if
you solve an lpa relaxation before every
decision
then uh the
the lp solar would just starve the
pseudo boolean solver
so that's the first challenge how you
balance your time allocation
another problem is that suppose you do
run your lp solver it tells
you that given the trail you have your
residual problem is infeasible you
should backtrack
what should the pseudo-boolean solver do
well it should backtrack i guess
but it can't it can only do conflict
analysis
so it needs a violated constraint but
there is no violated constraint because
if there were a violated constraint the
pb solver would have clearly
used it more subtly maybe
the lp solver is telling you to
backtrack because of some rounding error
of course in a boolean solver you can't
have rounding errors i mean you have
you need to have sound recently
um third interesting question you have a
lot of
cut constraints being generated in the
lp solver should we
give them to the pseudo boolean solver
also and in fact
the conflict driven learning that is
happening in the pseudoboolean solver is
also a cut generation
as it were should we give these cuts
you can make this formal although i'm
not doing so here but should these cuts
be passed on to the
to the lp solver so let me tell you what
we did
um in a collaboration with
the the skip team in berlin with klexner
so we balance time by keeping track of
the total number of pivots in simplex
and we make sure roughly that the total
number of pivots is never more than the
total number of conflicts that the
pseudo-boolean solver has seen
so if this is not satisfied then we
don't run the lps over
but whenever this equality is
satisfied and it's time to make a
decision then we say okay now the
pseudo-boolean solver can maybe consult
the lp solver
then we run it only for p pivots
which is some bound because otherwise
the lp solver might never get back to us
and we might time out so if we run for
more than people say then we just time
out
but we don't like that because that's
wasted time on an lp call that didn't
provide any information
so if that happens we also double this
limit p which means that
in the future we'll probably call the lp
solver maybe half as often
but we're twice as likely maybe to to
get meaningful results
this problem of having a doing conflict
analysis is actually not a big deal
farca's lemma tells us that if we are
infeasible then we can
efficiently compute the linear
combination of constraint that is
violated
so we'll do this and we'll add this as a
new constraint
this linear combination we'll add it as
a new constraint to the solver
and then we can say hey actually i have
a new constraint in your database and
it's violated and then the pseudo
boolean source says aha let me do
conflict analysis
and if there are rounding errors this
constraint is not violated and then we
just ignore it and continue
and then we've exploited uh trying to
share
uh these mip style cuts with the pb
solver we also tried sharing uh learned
cuts
to the lp solver okay
um so why is this different from what
mips always do so now i'm running out of
time i think i'll maybe skip this so
this is like trying to
explain in mid language what sudo
boolean conflict analysis is but i'm
running out of time
you'll have to refer to the pre-recorded
material for this i think the the
moral of this is that so
what mib solvers are doing is similar
but different so the propagation is
stronger but slower
and the conflict analysis i claim is
actually weaker
because you're not operating on the
linear constraints you're operating on
disjunctive clauses extracted from these
linear constraints and that's
exponentially weaker
plus when you're running a pseudo
boolean solver you don't have the issue
with a floating point so how does this
perform
so here are these tricky knapsack
benchmarks again and we run running sat
so this is this green thing and then we
add communication with the lp solver
suplex from skip
this is this blue line and then we add
uh the gomori cuts from the lp solver to
the pb solver and that's this
and then we even share learned cuts
from the pb solver to the lp solver and
we get a further improvement and uh
pseudo boolean solvers without these
techniques are like down here
so clearly these techniques pay off for
knapsack problems um
here are the same benchmarks as before
the oh
sub well some of them here the pseudo
boolean competition decision instances
optimization instances
some zero one interdelinear programming
problems from the
mplib and
you can see that in every category the
original rounding set or skip
is better but somehow the mixed solver
rounding set plus linear programming
integration is always an
honorable second best so if you had to
pick one solver
you should pick it because it's like has
a well-rounded performance it's never
much worse than the
best one which wasn't what we were
shooting for we were shooting for being
best but
you know we couldn't get that so second
best
it turns out that of course
adding lp solar incomes at the cost in
particular on pseudo-boolean decision
instances we lose out
on satisfiable instances we sold fewer
not because the search
is worse but because the search is
slower so
it's it's the solar gets more
intelligent but it doesn't pay off
um for the knapsack benchmarks we saw
that sharing
gomori cuts is helpful not so much for
mip instances and sudo boolean instances
and then we looked at one interesting
thing like how useful are different
constraints so it turns out that these
focus constraints
are super useful it seems they appear
much more often than your average
standard constraint in later conflict
analysis
however remember that these forecast
constraints we plug them in and then we
do
pseudo boolean conflict analysis based
on these constraints and the final
pseudo boolean constraints that you
learn from these conflict analysis
they're
actually worse than your average regular
constraint
it seems at least based on the
statistics statistics we have we don't
know why
um so
how would the cnf encoding with the sats
already do albert asks well this
is essentially what naps is so
naps is like re-encoding to cnf and
running a cdcl solver
so the answer is not great
and then you can ask but how would a how
would a mac sat solver do
and we don't know because the max ad
solvers don't read
sudo boolean input so this is something
that i think
should be changed so that we could
because i think that
i think the best uh the best uh max ad
solvers will probably be much better
than this and might even beat us but
they don't read the correct format right
now so it's hard to compare
okay so but again this is just you know
there's lots of
things you could do here uh improve the
heuristics
i think we could do a lot of smarter cut
generation smarter sharing
maybe dynamically allocate the time for
sudo boolean solving an lp solving
dependent
depending on some measurement how much
the solvers are contributing
it would be nice to to understand which
constraints are good or bad can we
somehow make use of the
solution to the lp relaxation to guide
the pseudo boolean solver
when it's making decisions i mentioned
already pre-solving would be nice to
have in sudo boolean solvers
why not take the pseudo boolean conflict
analysis and plug in
mere cuts instead of division well there
are reasons both for and against i think
but it's definitely something i would
like to do
take a core guided max ad solver or a
core guided
pseudo boolean solver or an implicit
hitting set base through the boolean
solver which doesn't
exist and combine it with an lp solver
in a similar way
um that's an open direction what
is lacking in rounding sat is it's
fairly good at proving optimality but
it's pretty lousy at this point in time
with actually finding the solutions
which is good to be able to do if you
want to prove optimality and it helps to
have a solution to prove
optimality for this is another
research direction for mid i do believe
that
there should be a payoff if you have
better if you try to use suitable and
conflict analysis rather than cdcl
conflict analysis
one other interesting idea is to solve
actually general zero one
mid problems with floating point
variables by having a pseudo boolean
solver taking part of the boolean part
and then the floating point variables
could be taken care of by an lp solver
lots of ideas that you could try out i
think but time is out
almost so if i try to sum up what i said
today
and also what i said in my well it
wasn't quite nine hours of pre-recorded
lectures but i think it's
maybe something like three and a half
four hours
um pseudo-boolean optimization
is an expressive formalism it's true
that
you can have even more expressive
formalisms like uh satisfiability
modular theories and constraint
programming but
but a large number of problems you can
express them
very naturally as pseudobudden
optimization problems
and then you can attack them and there
are different
approaches for this you can use set
solving and max sat
you can use mixed interlinear
programming you can use the
cutting planes based suitable and
reasoning
and the point is these are seem to be
complementary approaches
so i believe there's room for synergies
i believe there's room
for getting more mileage out of these
techniques by just by by reading up on
what they are
understanding what they are and then
trying to combine them uh
lots of of highly non-trivial questions
when it comes to
designing algorithms and it's not so
hard to actually design
complicated algorithms but then you have
to implement them so that they run
blisteringly fast
and then a thing like unit propagation
is really really key
because if you're losing a linear factor
in your unit propagation then you're
dead
um and then there's lots of i think
there are lots of nice
theoretical questions that said about
subsystems of cunning planes
about stabbing planes understanding the
power of
core guided approaches with extension
variables understanding
how they compare to this implicit
implicit hitting set approach
this is not normally the kind of proof
complexity theory that we do
but it is a kind of theory that could
really be helpful to practitioners and
inform
their design choices and i do believe
that if you're somewhere in between
these areas
so it's tricky because you need to be
able to understand
different communities that speak
different languages but if you do this
that means that you can sometimes see
connections that
are obvious with hindsight so i believe
there might be quite a lot of low
hanging fruit and above all i think it's
a lot of fun to work on this so
so i hope that some of you during the
semester will join me in exploring these
problems and thank you for attending the
talk
today thank you jacob for an excellent
talk uh
everyone should i'll clap my hands where
you can see and hear it
and hopefully the rest of you have
joined in um it is
exactly 10 30 so there's both the
possibility of joining in gather town
but i suggest first we open the floor to
some questions and discussion here
and then uh i'd encourage everyone to go
over to uh gather town
afterwards to talk a little bit so uh
we're open for questions or
comments et cetera other discussion
so apparently there's two questions that
i missed
so um mip solvers
like skip use a cut pool they score cuts
and only consider those that score high
enough
do any pb solvers do something like that
well so firstly i'm only aware of one
like native sulu boolean solver with
with lp integration
um namely the the recent running set
implementation i mean combining sat or
constraint programming with lp solving
is certainly not a
revolutionary new idea it's like an
obvious idea but it seems
pretty hard to make it work and i think
one of the key contributions actually of
our work probably which was not my idea
but the idea of my
postdoc joe divrent was this idea of
somehow balancing the time to make sure
that the lp solder gets time to run
but doesn't starve the pbsolder i think
that's a really nice
insight
given that what we did was basically we
tried to copy
um more or less what the map solvers do
so we generate a bunch of constraints
and then we try to keep constraints that
are not
so parallel to previously added
constraints and so on and so forth but i
think the short answer is i think
there's lots of room for improvement
probably um so
i mean there's a lot of smart things
that mips already do that we
don't do just because we over on the
surveillance side we have nobody has
investigated it
to the best of my knowledge and i think
it should be investigated it could
probably pay off i mean
the experimental results that i told you
about sort of indicates that there's a
clear payoff um
here's my answer to that question do
i see any real world applications for
counting or enumerating models of pb
constraints i think i'm the wrong
person to ask that question so i don't
do real world applications i do theory
like and then sometimes there comes
interesting computational problems from
the
practical side and then i try to solve
them but i really don't care about the
application so much
for me it's like you know the challenge
of solving a pseudo
formula with an objective function
but
[Music]
i mean quite potentially there are a lot
of problems that you can
model in pseudo-boolean form instead of
cnf and all the model counting
applications for those
i guess would be would be relevant also
for potentially for
for pseudo-boolean formulas i think
there are
put tens i'm a little bit
uh out of my comfort zone here but i
think something like weighted model
counting is fairly
natural to express with pseudo-boolean
constraints
um that could be a possible application
other people in the audience might be
better placed
to answer this question though
i think that's the least bad answer i
can give
okay good um any more questions or
discussion
um
so there is a comment about not for
jakob about having a proposal reading
group about
pseudo-boolean solvers ask mossmo so
i think to my mind that sounds like a
great idea and i'm sure others would
agree
probably you just have to follow up on
the proposal and start the reading group
um just take a pic pick a few papers to
get started with and
we can open a channel on ice discord for
that
i don't know if if practitioners do
polymath but you could certainly
imagine a polymath project on like
taking a good
basic solver and then exploring all
kinds of settings and really
understanding what's going on
this is a little bit related to i think
what also came up in in armin's talk the
other day
that to to understand to see what these
solvers are doing i mean i think there's
lots of room for
[Music]
developing a rigorous scientific
understanding of what the solvers do
we're really
in the dark as to why certain techniques
perform well and others don't there's
lots of room
for improvement here
all right sounds like that's all
discussion so
thank you again jakub for a fabulous
talk
and the gather town link is in the chat
window
anyone would like to come over and try
to mingle
virtually on the screen and
otherwise thank you very much
thank you thank you